ces dernières semaines les nouvelles qui
me parviennent de russie sont
inquiétantes des émeutes raciales sans
précédent ont éclaté à travers le pays
je décide de me rendre en carélie à la
frontière finlandaise c'est ici que tout
a commencé dans la ville de cosne dabaga
une ville dont le nom résonne désormais
sur tout le territoire comme l'exemple
d'un laboratoire d'une russie blanche
une semaine après les émeutes on me dit
qu'ici il ne reste plus un seul étranger
que s'est il donc passé dans cette ville
devenue en quelques jours le symbole de
la haine de l'autre
mon chauffeur de taxi dima 25 ans était
à l'essai ne t'y un de ceux qui a mené
la chasse aux étrangers il en est fier
ici avant les gens vivaient dans la peur
surtout la nuit on a bien fait chasser
les étrangers
on est vraiment mieux sans eux
fin août tout a commencé ici au café
tchaïka là où la jeunesse sera soumis le
samedi soir une bagarre éclate entre des
russes et des jeunes venus l'azerbaïdjan
et de tchétchénie
après ça on est sortis dans la rue on a
tout cassé tous les magasins qui
appartenait aux étrangers
c'est ici que tout a commencé à quoi bon
le pogrom
programme incroyable c'était bien
tout se regarder il ne reste plus rien
il faut expulser tous les étrangers de
la ville tous jusqu'au dernier on ne
sera jamais au calme avec eux
la ville doit être annulée
[Applaudissements]
comme la pagaille est fière de ces
pogroms ce module autre époque une
période tragique de la russie
le siècle dernier c'était contre les
juifs j'ai retrouvé ces images du début
des émeutes filmé par un habitant de la
ville la population est dans la rue elle
clame vengeance les visages sont jeunes
russes est plein de haine
[Applaudissements]
en tête du cortège de la haine je
découvre alexandre belhow le leader d'un
mouvement ultra nationalistes venus
spécialement de moscou avec ses troupes
leur but nettoyer la rue sol il donne 24
heures aux étrangers pour quitter la
ville
[Applaudissements]
jo
sur ces autres images filmées d'une
fenêtre j'assiste à la colère d'une
ville devenue folle
dès la fin du discours la foule
saccagent tout sur son passage elle veut
le départ de ce qu'en russie on appelle
le cul noir ceux qui viennent d'asie
centrale et du caucase
des centaines de jeunes prennent
d'assaut tous les commerces des
arméniens des géorgiens d'algérie et des
tchétchènes trois jours d'émeutes de
pillage de destruction la police locale
laisse faire
le bilan est lourd des dizaines de
blessés et une ville mise à sac
retour au calme les jeunes russes devenu
maître des lieux parade toutes les
familles d'immigrés qui habitait là
depuis parfois plusieurs générations
doivent quitter la ville
ils nous regardent comme des sauvages il
ne nous considèrent pas comme des êtres
humains
regardez nos enfants ils ne sont pas
pires que les enfants russes on en a
aussi des blonds aux yeux bleus
mon réveil shastri aujourd'hui les
étrangers sont partis et ce sont les
russes qui font du commerce en ville
il n'ya plus depuis noir
avant ils se croyaient les maîtres ici
maintenant c'est fini ils ont peur de
revenir
dima me conduit au marché ou jusqu'aux
émeutes la majorité des vendeurs
venaient d'asie centrale ils sont
presque tous partis
tous ces endroits étaient tenus par des
tadjik et les tchétchènes voilà tout ce
qu'il reste
et vous vous avez peur
non on ne veut pas parler et pourquoi
ces images ne sont entrés qu'en france
on ne veut pas on ne peut pas
je ne perde pas
moi je vais leur dire
vous comprenez depuis les émeutes avec
tout ce qui s'est passé on vit dans la
peur
on n'en peut plus
[Musique]
on est tous terrorisés
aujourd'hui ces quelques vendeurs
arménien quand ce aussi quitter la ville
le plus vite possible sur le marché
désormais la place et aux russes
on est vraiment mieux aujourd'hui
nous étions envahi
maintenant quand je me balade
je me sens parmi les nôtres les slaves
il n'ya plus que nous les russes on
respire je me sent tranquille enfin au
calme
on est vraiment mieux entre russes au
moins on peut faire du business avec les
étrangers il y avait toujours des
problèmes
une ville-symbole une ville blanche
exclusivement depuis des émeutes
similaires ont éclaté dans dix autres
régions en russie
je pars à la recherche de ceux qui ont
fui la ville j'apprends que certains
d'entre eux se sont réfugiés à 150 km de
là un lieu secret sous haute
surveillance de la police
certains habitants de caunes dabaga aux
menaces et de retrouver les réfugiés où
qu'ils soient et de se venger
bonjour et spawn d'hirson des
correspondants de la télévision
française
bonjour comment ça va bonjour
après le rassemblement ils sont devenus
fous ils ont hurlé on va découper en
morceaux toutes les femmes et les
enfants des étrangers j'ai à peine eu le
temps de rassembler quelques affaires
j'ai pris mes deux enfants et je me suis
enfui je ne veux plus jamais retourné à
combes dabaga je ne suis pas kamikaze
ils ont dit qu'ils me tueraient si je
reviens
ils ont dit ça oui ils ont des styles
revient on te turas avec des cocktails
molotov
toute cette semaine c'est le résultat
d'années de guerre interminable dans le
caucase et aussi de la situation sociale
dans la région
ici beaucoup d'entreprises ont fermé les
gens sont au chômage les jeunes n'ont
rien à faire alors s'il cherche un bouc
émissaire un coupable
est le coupable à travers les siècles
ç'a toujours été l'autre l'étranger
[Musique]
je vais
ils sont deux cents à vivre ici
essentiellement des femmes et des
enfants
aujourd'hui ils n'ont nulle part où
aller
[Musique]
les autorités régionales ne leur ont
proposé l'hébergement que pour quelques
semaines
al'approche de l'hiver un exil intérieur
dans une russie qui les rejette
[Musique]
je retourne à kolda paga quelques jours
après les émeutes c'est toujours le
couvre feu en ville les autorités
locales ont décrété un état d'urgence
anti étrangers
dima veut me faire rencontrer ses amis
depuis que le bar tchaïka a brûlé les
jeunes se retrouvent désormais dans une
salle de billard au centre ville
les copains de dimanche entre 20 et 25
ans la plupart d'entre eux ont pris part
aux émeutes
ces jeunes n'appartiennent pas à une
organisation ultra nationalistes mais
leur discours ne s'en éloigne guerre
tout ça c'est à cause de leur religion
ils sont musulmans ils sont capables de
tuer n'importe qui juste comme ça pour
un geste ou un mot de travers oui c'est
ça et tu te tue en criant allah akbar
tout ça c'est dans leur sens dès
l'enfance on leur apprend égorger des
moutons ensuite il égorge des hommes on
va se défendre nous mêmes on a des armes
si l'état ne peut pas nous défendre on
prendra les choses en main
oui le peuple exige qu'on l'ait des
portes tous
tous jusqu'au dernier c'est la seule
solution
moi si j'étais gouvernants le carélien
je ferai des villes fermées chaque ville
serait entouré par des postes de
contrôle qui vérifierait la nationalité
l'identité de ceux qui rentrent et notre
lé numéro de matricule à sion les allées
et venues et les heures d'entrée et de
sortie une ville fermée c'est ce qu'il
ya de mieux comme à l'époque de l'union
soviétique
[Musique]
et
je repense sans cesse à tous ces clichés
racistes qui nourrissent les
conversations de ces jeunes russes à ce
fantasme collectif sur l'ennemi de
préférence musulmans l'étranger devenu
l'envahisseur le meurtrier sanguinaire
la cible à abattre
le lendemain je quitte la carélie et sa
folie nationalistes pour me rendre à
saint pétersbourg à 500 km de kolda pas
gars
là aussi la ville n'est pas épargné par
les sentiments xénophobes
ici comme dans le reste du pays 80 % des
russes à prendre ce qu'il s'est passé en
quarts et nuit
impossible de quitter tout à fait comme
dabaga la ville symbole est dans tous
les esprits dans les slogans de ces
manifestants ils veulent reproduire
partout ce qui s'est passé là-bas
chasser l'étranger
ils sont quelques centaines ce matin des
familles mais aussi beaucoup de ski nahd
et d'organisations d'extrême droite
toujours aux avant-postes des
manifestations xénophobes en russie je
reconnais l'homme qui haranguait la
foule a comme la bagarre depuis il est
devenu la coqueluche des médias
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi je dois y aller
alexandre béland est venu tout
spécialement de moscou pour vous parler
cela fait du bien de voir de vrais russe
des blues hurle
il faut aujourd'hui qu'on leur montre ce
qu'est la grande unité nationale russe
il faut que l'on créé des comités de
patriotes à travers le pays en sibérie
dans le grand nord à moscou saint
pétersbourg
je vous dis que le chemin de la victoire
est devant nous nous allons prendre le
pouvoir en russie
gloire à la russie
noir est là aussi
[Applaudissements]
la russie aux russes c'est normal c'est
comme la france aux français à qui
d'autre au chinois peut-être
oui moi je crois qu'il vaut mieux une
guerre que de laisser les étrangers nous
écraser mieux vaut encore la guerre
bravo vous avez bien raison
je vous conseille que des émeutes comme
en carélie ne se reproduise
bien sûr après condat paga il ya eu des
émeutes dans une dizaine de villes
russes ce n'est que national
le parti d'alexandre belhow assure être
un simple mouvement de citoyens
pourtant parmi la foule j'aperçois des
membres de l'union slave la principale
organisation néo-nazie en russie ils
assurent le service d'ordre de la
manifestation
je vais à la rencontre
ils me donnent rendez vous le lendemain
nous avons rendez vous dans un lieu
secret à 50 km de saint-pétersbourg une
base militaire désaffectée
c'est leur camp d'entraînement
une fois par semaine ils se réunissent
par petits groupes ils s'imaginent en
combattant de la race blanche
ça c'est notre instrument de libération
nationale
il prône le national socialisme
ils se disent à rien et fils d'hitler
qu'importe si la russie a perdu 27
millions d'hommes contre l'allemagne
nazie
l'acide du jour un masque à gaz et
l'étoile de david
l'union slave revendique dix mille
membres en général des jeunes au chômage
ou issus des classes pauvres
ces jeunes se vante d'avoir des soutiens
au kremlin au fsb l'ancien kgb ainsi
qu'au sein de la police ils ont des
armes et or et étant entraînée par
d'anciens spetsnaz les forces spéciales
russes
des gens haut placés nous soutiennent
lorsque nous serons enfin au kremlin et
bien nous les troupes de l'union slave
nous serons chargés de contrôler les
villes à travers le territoire russe
et pour cela il est impératif de savoir
utiliser des armes
oui nous sommes prêts à prendre les
armes pour défendre nos intérêts ce
notre peuple et notre terre
dridi
tous ceux qui ne sont pas de race
blanche sont à éliminer tu nous avons
notre peuple notre race et nous
défendons ses intérêts
si l'état n'est pas capable de le faire
nous le ferons nous mêmes nous les
russes on en a les moyens
et ce qui s'est passé en carélie montre
que le peuple soutient notre cause
il rêve de prendre le pouvoir en
attendant les combattants de l'union
slave jouent à la guerre
après les séances de tir il y à
l'anéantissement de l'ennemi apprendre à
égorger où tu es à mains nues
depuis les émeutes de carélie les jeunes
guerriers de l'union slave aime
s'afficher en ville dans les lieux
publics
j'ai bon
ils paradent sûrs de leur impunité d'une
popularité croissante en russie ces
groupes de jeunes qui portent des
insignes néo nazis ne choque plus
personne
et de plus en plus de russes aux exprimé
ouvertement leur haine de l'autre
je
moi je suis professeur à l'université et
je sens le danger qui est là partout
on nous agresse nous les russes en
permanence et qui nous agressent les
gens d'asie centrale lady gaga les
tchétchènes
ce que défendent ces jeunes de l'union
slave la russie aux russes je suis pour
je soutiens leurs idées et beaucoup de
gens en russie aujourd'hui pensent comme
moi sans oser le dire
vous avez vu ce qu'il s'est passé en
carélie on nous envahit de partout alors
bien sûr que je suis d'accord avec ces
jeunes
ricanements des jeunes néonazis à
l'arrière de l'autobus un homme vient de
monter il est originaire d'ouzbékistan
il sait bien qu'il n'a pas intérêt à
s'approcher de nous il sait ce qu'il
veut lui arrive et il sait de quoi on
est capable des gens comme lui on les
fait disparaître
vous sentez que le racisme augmente en
dessous
un homme terrorisé au milieu de jeunes
de 20 ans déterminée à nettoyer la
russie aient migré d'asie centrale du
caucase les victimes des commandos du
racisme russe se comptent chaque année
par dizaines quelques jours avant notre
tournage ils ont fait exploser une bombe
sur un marché à moscou bilan 10 morts et
40 blessés
la recette de l'explosif était sur leur
site internet sur ces mêmes sites
l'union slave appellent régulièrement
aux meurtres des nombreux
mois
ouah voilà
effets de mise en scène un mélange
sordide de mauvais goût et d' abject
comme ces images de pendaison fictive
contre les ennemis du peuple russe
où cette recette grossière pour éliminer
l'adversaire
[Musique]
et le jeu
[Applaudissements]
sur ces sites sont aussi diffusé des
images réelles de tabassage de
ratonnades et parfois même demeure
à l'image comme au son une ultra
violence revendiquée comme la seule
solution et qui gagne peu à peu toute la
russie
[Musique]
après une vague sans précédent de la
sinne à saint pétersbourg a été
rebaptisée la capitale du fascisme en
europe
je rencontre ue no soul tout neuf il
vient du tadjikistan sa petite-fille
cours chez d'un a été tué en plein jour
par de jeunes skinheads
j'étais avec ma fille elle avait 8 ans
et 4 mois et puis il y avait aussi mon
neveu de cinq ans on rentre à la maison
les enfants était à mes côtés
il jouait riait comme le font les
enfants
et puis on est passé par là pour rentrer
chez nous c'est là qu'ils me sont tombés
dessus et
ils m'ont roué tôt ils avaient des
barres de fer et matraques ils m'ont
frappée à la tête
je suis tombé j'ai essayé de me relever
mais il frappait
le maine expliquant sa pote mon neveu se
cacher sous la voiture pas de celle à la
celle qu'elle a
et ma fille ils l'ont tué là bas
nationale brive est chrétien elle a
commencé à s'enfuir elle criait voilà
c'est ici qu'ils ont tués
j'ai repris conscience j'ai appelé à
l'aide et les voisins ont accouru
on a ramassé le corps de ma fille elle
est morte dans mes bras
quand on lui a retiré ses vêtements
sur tout son corps il y avait des traces
de coups de couteau ils l'ont massacré
onze coups de couteau contre une
fillette de 8 ans
les voisins de la famille sont encore
sur le choc jamais un meurtre aussi
violent contre une enfant n'avait eu
lieu en russie
ce sont des jeunes des adolescents de 15
ans qui sortent de l'école et qui se
rassemblent dans la cour comme cela là
bas des gosses de l'orage
c'est terrifiant ce qu'il se passe en
russie aujourd'hui
ces jeunes n'ont plus dé couteaux sur
eux des petits couteaux que cache dans
leur poche et comme la plupart d'entre
eux des tests l'agent d'asie centrale eh
bien ils peuvent décider à n'importe
quel moment dont tu as tout simplement
11 coups de couteau pour eux ce n'est
rien
les assassins de ma fille était mineure
et les jurés ils ont eu pitié d'eux mais
pas de ma fille qui a été assassinée
sauvagement
ils ont été condamnés pour hooliganisme
et non pour meurtre comment est ce
possible
les meurtriers de cours chez davet entre
15 et 17 ans des lycéens l'un d'entre
eux vivaient dans la même cour que la
famille sous le tout neuf ils n'ont été
condamné qu'à deux ans et demi de prison
je ne mets pas ici
je retrouve les militants de l'union
slave les commandos de la race blanche
que nous avions filmé à l'entraînement
il me conduisent dans leur quartier
général un appartement au coeur de saint
pétersbourg ils se réunissent ici une
fois par semaine depuis quatre ans ils
n'ont jamais été inquiétés
une cache de néo nazis qu'ils appellent
le musée du national socialisme
c'est ici qu'ils décident des actions à
venir
aujourd'hui il assume totalement les
assassinats d'hier
[Musique]
que pensez-vous du meurtre de la petite
fille tadjik
mais vous en pensez quoi
compenser le meurtre de la petite fille
tadjik
elle a mis ce qu'elle méritait elle dit
les blagues drogue à l'école
et voilà le résultat
un patriote me donner un juste châtiment
il a fait ce qu'il fallait faire
pour que l'on tue il faut une vraie
raison là c'est clair si quelqu'un d'une
autre race bafoue nos lois et bien le
reçois ce qu'ils méritent c'est comme ça
et je ne peux qu'approuver summer
mais elle n'avait que 8 ans
comment pouvait justifier le meurtre
d'une fille est alors c'est petit fille
dans dix ans elle donnera naissance à
neuf islamistes vous comprenez
nous on ne fait pas de différence d'âge
calé huit ou vingt ans ça n'a pas
d'importance
un jour elle grandira et elle sourire à
notre terre
des jeunes de 20 ans qui revendique
ouvertement la mise à mort d'une
fillette sans craindre les conséquences
c'est bien là les racines du mal
beaucoup d'experts en russie pense que
si des groupes néo-nazis agissent avec
autant d'impunité c'est que le pouvoir
les utilisent pour créer un climat de
peur à un an et demi des élections
présidentielles je me rends dans la
banlieue de saint pétersbourg pour
rencontrer valentina ouzou nova qui
étudie depuis vingt ans les mouvements
d'extrême droite
j'ai rendez vous dans un lieu secret
valentina ait menacé de mort son adjoint
a été assassiné par les jeunes néonazis
l'année dernière
la situation politique en russie est
très instable
il est très possible qu'à un moment ou
un autre le pouvoir aura besoin de se
servir de ces groupuscules fascistes
pour l'instant ils les gardent juste
sous contrôle
ils savent très bien qu'ils sont ils le
savent parfaitement ils observent leur
progression
mais quand bien même le pouvoir réagir
et aujourd'hui avec le problème ce sont
les mentalités
c'est trop tard
la société russe est aujourd'hui à la
recherche systématique d'un énorme au
cinéaste rare
donc les russes on repère en permanence
et l'autre de l'étranger tant qu'ils ne
se rendront pas compte que nos enfants
ne peuvent grandir dans un monde basé
sur la haine
le pays va vers une voie sans retour
il est temps de reconnaître que nous
sommes devenus des bêtes sauvages et
qu'il faut revenir en arrière parmi les
hommes sinon c'est la fin
chronique d'une barbarie ordinaire à
saint pétersbourg après le meurtre de
cours chez da plusieurs étudiants
africains ont été la cible des
groupuscules fascistes
je vais à l'université de
télécommunications dans le coeur
historique de la ville un institut où
l'on retrouve des étudiants depuis le 30
nationalités
en avril dernier un étudiant sénégalais
les arts samba a été assassiné en pleine
rue par un groupe de néo-nazis et 5
heures du matin il sortait de boîte de
nuit avec ses amis il a reçu une balle
en pleine tête je retrouve valentin et
michel qui était avec lui ce soir la
samba un jeune homme brillant qui
terminait ses études d'ingénieur
il vivait depuis sept ans en russie avec
valentin il avait créé l'association des
étudiants étrangers lors d'une facilité
l'intégration et surtout le dialogue
avec les rues
depuis la mort de samba les étudiants
étrangers ont peur la plupart viennent
des anciens pays ami de l'ex urss
pour eux il est toujours plus facile
d'obtenir des bourses en russie qu'en
occident
à la sortie des coups je retrouve michel
et ses amis des russes pour la plupart
tous sont encore sous le choc de
l'assassinât de samba
quand on a appris la mort de samba on
n'arrivait pas à y croire on a appris ça
à la télévision le soir et on s'est tous
après le pensait pas qu'une chose
pareille était possible en russie on
puisse tuer un étudiant juste comme ça
c'est vraiment terrifiant ce qui se
passe ici
tout ça c'est à cause du manque
d'éducation des gens je ne peux pas
comprendre une telle attitude vis-à-vis
des étudiants africains c'est sans doute
parce que la vie est difficile en russie
mais
de plus en plus des gens éprouvent du
ressentiment de la haine alors il se
retourne contre ceux qui parlent une
autre langue qui ont une autre couleur
de peau
moi j'espère qu'avec le temps la
situation économique ira mieux dans
notre pays les gens deviendront civilisé
et alors il n'y aura plus ces crimes
odieux
lorsque michel et rémy sorte de court le
danger est partout certains sites
néo-nazis ont diffusé des photos
d'étudiants africains comme cible à
abattre
au revoir
bon courage faites attention à vous
commencez à voir
les attaques pour ne pas
tuer avec attention on se demande quand
on ira chez nous mais on aura la
speedster psychose de marché ou regarder
comme ça tu es gamin gauche à droite
toujours comme ça qu on m a mis qui
plaisent en tête il dit quand tu sors tu
dis pas que je senti que je vais tenter
ma chance et tu vois la tentation si
vous incident survient vivre
sur le chemin pour rentrer au foyer qui
se trouve à l'autre bout de la ville
michel héry micro azannaï visa visa
était la petite amie de samba il
comptait sur marianne à
michel tu as entendu ce que vient de me
dire celui qui est passé
il m'a dit fais attention au sida
qu'est ce qui voulait dire il voulait
dire à moi et ma copine attention fille
russe ces africains vont vous contaminer
tu te rends compte 1 ça m'arrivait tout
le temps ce genre de réflexion avec
samba
ce qui m'a fait le plus mal c'est
lorsqu'un jour après nous est fait
agresser par des jeunes dans la rue on
s'était enfui dans le métro est là une
femme est venue vers moi
et elle m'a dit des filles comme toi il
faudrait leur faire une opération pour
qu'elle ne puisse pas avoir d'enfant
je n'oublierai jamais ce jour là
le soir je vais au foyer des étudiants
africains là où vivait samba
[Musique]
il voit rien sénégalais camerounais le
foyer leur unique refuge depuis la mort
de samba ils ont trop peur de sortir le
soir
à tizi si chère à sécurité tout un
symbole mais quand tu franchis la porte
quand tu sors qu'il fasse il apporte
quoi de l'accusé un mécanicien
au jour un atterrissage à kigali les
premiers sur cinq ans et que dire de
cette histoire
d'accompagner
donc pas la voir manger bien
boire voilà un vélo sans lever ou ça
vous le savez que chaque jour que tu as
envie c'est une fête en fait c'est moi
c'est pas comme j'ai toujours dit aux
amis a réussi j'ai tout vu non je me
sens déjà pré rentrée j'ai vu le plus
idiot de la rue qui m'agace élevé j'ai
vu les policiers mais taper dessus du
désert délictuelle maps et les [ __ ]
j'ai vu des professeurs sont moqués de
moi j'ai vu des camarades au boulot se
moquer de moi je crois pas que j'avais
quelque chose à voir dans ce prix et
c'est ce qu'ils déploient en fait ce que
chaque jour que tu es si chaque jeu
quotidien dans la rue c'est comme si tu
venais d'arriver là et c'est comme si tu
tombé du ciel notre camarade chaque jour
qui nous voilà qu'ils ont subi on n'a
jamais compris cela un peuple est
constamment surpris c'est donc ce n'est
pas du tout saisir
c'est pas marrant tout sa
solitude d'un foyer devenu comme une
prison rêve de retour au pays
en quittant ce soir là michel valentin
et rémy je pensait repartir le lendemain
en france mais le matin de mon départ
j'apprends la mort d'un autre étudiant
étranger un indien en dernière année de
médecine tué de sept coups de couteau
par des néonazis valentin michel et rémy
sont venus tout de suite l'impression de
vivre un cauchemar sans fin
regardez c'est son sang sur le trottoir
ils l'ont traîné là
ici tu peux crier tant que tu veux
personne ne peut entendre
que l'on tue et se sont enfuis sans que
personne ne réagisse
et hier soir alors qu'on était là autour
du corps de notre ami sur le trottoir eh
bien tu sais ce qu'ils ont fait les
étudiants russes ils vivent au quatrième
au cinquième étage du foyer
ils ont jeté des préservatifs usagés sur
son corps des préservatifs usagés tu te
rends compte de la haute du cinquième
voilà comment ils nous considèrent dans
ce pays
c'est ça
je me demande si peut-être que les
ambassades qui sont allés présenter
s'ils peuvent faire quelque chose à ce
que
tous les gars qui sont ici parce qu'il
faut donner dans les céréales face à ce
gouvernement là
ils ont signé une coopération qu'on peut
les étudiants étrangers venus se fait
tuer la société d'équipé ici y'a pas de
souci parce que
symptôme de cette rue sous qui s'enfonce
chaque jour un peu plus dans la haine de
l'autre aucun étudiant russe ne s'est
déplacé pour la cérémonie en mémoire de
sept nouvelles victimes du racisme
il n'y a là que quelques dizaines
d'étrangers des étudiants qui comme
valentin michel aurait ni se retrouve
prisonnier d'un pays qui ne veut pas
deux prises au piège de la fureur russe